five things you probably never thought
could be turned into furniture are these
chairs real or just sketches they look
more like a computer design but are in
fact real they're made entirely of wire
czech artist Jung clutch finds
inspiration in design classics and he's
number five on today's list
he's remodeled us of Huffman's cube
chair and this 18th century Hui the 16th
design he recreates the contours of the
chair using wire it might not look
comfortable but they've won a number of
design awards is it leather or ceramic
no the material used to make these
furnishings comes from the ocean seaweed
is number four on a list of materials
that you probably never thought could be
turned into furniture danish designer
jonas édouard lives by the baltic sea
where there's certainly no shortage of
his favorite material he combines it
with paper to form a less than
appetizing dough which he turns into
lampshades or even chairs the ultimate
eco-friendly design
this furniture needs no assembly no
nails no screws it's held together
simply by thread and it's number three
on our list of unusual furniture various
pieces of wood or metal are put together
Anton Alvarez transforms these into
furniture by simply wrapping them in
hundreds of metres of thread
he's even developed a thread wrapping
machine to speed up the process it now
takes him two or three days to create
his colorful designer objects believe it
or not this man is also a furniture
designer Martin schlund builds cupboards
beds or whatever out of old cars how
about a Mercedes desk
or a bar made from a Fiat 500 he turned
a VW Beetle into a sofa and is number
two on our list of way-out design
customers either bring their own car or
denying their brand and year and March
in schlund finds a model but he only
uses cars that are no longer road worthy
this is carpentry like you've never seen
it before
Gavin Munroe from Britain doesn't build
his furniture he harvests it all of his
creations simply grow into shape they
are an entire plant and get number one
on a list of things you'd never think to
be turned into furniture using wire and
plastic frames this furniture farmer
decides how the plant will grow to
produce a chair for example then it's a
case of waiting it takes several years
to harvest the final product